[Applaudissements]
parti de la permanence de didier martin
venu du drapeau le cortège a tenté de se
rendre sans violence devant la
préfecture
mais tout le monde a été repoussée ici
par des gaz lacrymogènes
je vous propose d'écouter quelques
manifestants qui faisaient part de leur
colère et l'utilisation du 49-3 quelques
minutes avant le départ du cortège
effectivement on peut dire que le 49-3
quelque chose habituelle dans la vème
république mais là faut pas exagérer
quoi faut pas exagérer et là on est dans
un mouvement d gilet jaune qui dure
depuis plus de 18 mois des
manifestations qui ont commencé le 5
décembre des oppositions qui se sont
manifestés de partout peut-être pour
différentes raisons mais voilà il faut
arrêter quoi gouvernement a beaucoup
communiqué sur l'obstruction fans de
position mais c'est quand même
l'opposition qui a fait surgir des
points extrêmement importants comme par
exemple comment va être calculée la
retraite à la fin
les sénateurs et les députés devraient
en théorie représenter les les gens qui
sont là la nation est en fait ils
représentent plus rien puisque on leur
enlève le droit de d'être contre ce que
le banc ce gouvernement nous avions
demandé une audience en préfecture le
préfet nous a interdit la rue de la
préfecture
pourquoi on ne sait pas et elle nous a
balancé les gaz lacrymogènes
on commence à avoir vraiment un
gouvernement fébrile comme on dit un
colosse aux pieds d'argile
parce que il est de plus en plus mises
en cause par les citoyens ce projet de
loi les citoyens les salariés n'en
veulent pas comme vous avez pu
l'entendre des manifestants en colère
qui parle de déni de démocratie
les deux motions de censure seront
examinés ce soir et seront mises au vote
un gouvernement qui ne risque pas de
trembler ce soir puisqu'il a la majorité
absolue à l'assemblée nationale en tout
cas les manifestants ici se disent prêts
à continuer le combat
bien après ce vote à l'assemblée